[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
everybody back again final four live
presented by Wendy's we are still coming
to grips with what we just witnessed in
game one of the final four San Diego
State seemingly downed the entire game
to FAU clawing scratching inching their
way back and then hitting a game-winner
at the buzzer Robbie Hubble my main man
I'm swallowing a lollipop Tyler hands
for all a lifesaver Tyler hansborough
Robbie Hummel let's relive what we just
saw
before we get to this second game this
was our reaction
[Applause]
man
as the ball got to his hands Tyler goes
shoot it because at that moment it felt
like there was a lot of doubt we didn't
he had no options he had nothing going
for him but he was able to turn around
and get it to go now that we've had 15
minutes we walked around this Stadium
what do you think about it now has it
settled in at all
I've seen too many shots in this
tournament where they don't get it off
and the one thing you got to do is get
the shot off Marquis Noel yes yes our
example yep great composer got the shot
off I'm still amazed because it's not a
high quality look but the ball went in
unbelievable and uh very fitting for
this tournament just having the presence
of mine though to know what what time
you have so many people panic and shoot
a a much worse quality shot he at least
got to his pull-up as a right-handed
player the left-hand dribble pull-up is
what you want because it's the easier
footwork you don't have to really square
up you're already really square and I
just thought that the way he got to that
left hand was was really impressive and
this game San Diego State knocking off
Florida Atlantic has created a buzz in
this building that the first game did
not have in the beginning there was an
energy pulsating right now as Yukon
Miami has just started and UConn starts
off with a deep ball I want to get into
some uh breakdowns first but chuck
couldn't believe it here's what
Charles's view was uh he was just
sitting there hands on head he could not
believe it
two things about this next game Yukon
Miami UConn right now up three nothing
again they hit the three number one fans
you said it just now you look out there
Miami student section is filled Yukon is
about 15 filled there is a lot more
Miami fans in this Stadium right now
second thing when we were walking in the
hallways you guys looked at each other
when we passed Yukon their size really
stunned both of you talk about that well
right here we're seeing sunogo go get
offensive rebounds but with him and with
klingen that they have a massive size
advantage over a Miami team that wants
to play small and wants their guards to
get to the paint and drive it
I mean you you were staring at them you
were like eyeing them down as we were
walking by well UConn has a lot of sides
they're also one of the best rebounding
teams in the country and the real
question norchado mirror for Miami he's
their big he's got to stay out of foul
trouble because UConn has size and they
dominate the boards if Miami wants to
try to contain them he's got to be smart
and stay out of foul trouble but also
Jordan Hawkins been sick past couple
days and I was curious to see how he was
going to come out and play yeah he
looked okay
drama practice had a non-coveted illness
sat out practice yesterday came back and
he's playing and he hit the three yeah
Hawkins with the early three he's great
off the ball I mean he just flies around
and he's not just a catch-and-shoot guy
he's very comfortable catching and
shooting off the move which you see
that's really what separates guys yes at
every level I mean if you can run off
screens and fly around and be that guy
that's why he's going to be a good Pro
explosive score too there's been a lot
lot of games where he's kind of been
quiet then all of a sudden you see and
he kind of goes off for about 20. so
he's one of those guys that can kind of
put it in cruise and all of a sudden get
really hot so that would be you know a
big key for UConn definitely and he's
played himself probably into an NBA
player this year
Robbie the last game was a defensive
Scrappy team against a very versatile
keep it outside how would you sum up
Miami UConn as we get into this game
well Miami's about their four guards we
just watched Jordan Miller Missed a shot
what's wrong with him he didn't miss one
sunogo wow down at three it's not on The
Scouting Report really I
you keep talking though just about UConn
of Miami yeah yeah and with UConn just
the number of weapons they have they've
used Andre Jackson as a de facto point
forward he has been terrific at setting
people up Tristan Newton is a player
that's got multiple triple doubles on
the year they've got size they can run
with you they can shoot the basketball
they are playing the best ball out of
anybody in this tournament and have been
for two weeks and I just think for Miami
Tyler mentioned the foul trouble to Amir
that's going to be huge but their guards
the Hurricanes can really go
yeah Miami's a veteran group uh they
lost in the lead eight last year but to
me sunogo for UConn has been
Sunoco with another three sunogo came in
17-49 for sure wow he's the most
dominant player in the tournament so far
uh and UConn's been the most dominant
team as well they've won all uh for
their games by 15 more 15 or more points
in this tournament so to me wow that was
goaltending
that's where Jordan Miller 90 total but
15 or more in every game for UConn what
was interesting about UConn because you
guys are in this sport the entire year
to realize that they could have been a
number one seed if you take the
beginning of their year and the end of
the year and you just remove that weird
6-8 game stretch where they were losing
all these big east teams no one can
really explain what happened they lost
the game Xavier as well but they are the
hottest team that if you look at
beginning of the year and end of the
year it makes sense the middle is the
confusion there
oh veggie
that's a Wendy's wedgie that wedgie
brought to you by Wendy's Wendy's
wedgies well done I don't know
um but there this is a Yukon team that
we see the four but maybe they were more
talented than that fourth season I think
that shows just how good the Big East
was this year you get into a stretch
where you're running into some of these
teams Road games and college basketball
right are so hard to win you lose a
couple it's one of those mid-season
funks but they found their way and and
they have been just phenomenal in the
NCAA tournament yeah conference plays
definitely you know a key but Big East
was very tough that's true but also in
college when you get around that
Christmas holiday time a lot of teams
lose focus and you have finals and stuff
like that so they can slip up that's a
great point but their overall body of
work through the whole year they started
off extremely hot and the the clinging
kid has a lot of size and he comes in
and does work in a short amount of time
so if sunogo gets him out of trouble or
he goes down they have a big ready Off
the Bench to come in and he's been
unbelievable if he were to get more
consistent minutes I think he'd be he'd
be dominating just as just as Sunoco is
he is talented all right production
truck take us on the journey wherever
you want to go we are ready to go Yukon
these are our locks I have UConn winning
by five or more Robbie said I'll do you
one better we're gonna go seven or more
uh I went uh over four and a half times
horrible so Bob or Danny they're gonna
be in there uh Rob also wants to know go
over 17 and you're he's already at six
so we're looking good uh Tyler you went
over eight rebounds for sunogo and then
omir under 10 rebounds what was the
thinking there well I think UConn has
the size and UConn's one of the best
rebounding teams in the country so I
don't think you know nor chathamir he
has been foul prone uh in the past so
that could play a factor as well but I
don't think there's you know many teams
that dominate the rebounds like UConn
does so I went the under on that sunogo
I think this was easy for me I went over
on his rebounds so we both took UConn
would that have been one of your picks
as well UConn I picked UConn to win them
for the tournament so I'm not the whole
thing the whole thing I'm not going to
change now I think it's cheap pounds
four to lose did you do a bracket with
like your friends or like a big
competition or anything no I did a
public bracket uh just to back it up
yeah uh you can uh it's uh so what was
it about UConn before the because now
when you see the road and it makes sense
what was it before the tournament like
did you know that you wanted to pick
Yukon and then you filled out your
bracket or did it just kind of happen
that way just kind of happened that way
but I also think UConn's had the
toughest road to the to the final four
and also Jordan Hawkins has really
become explosive and really developed
into a consistent score from the outside
yeah and you know their one question was
was do they have a point guard and then
you know Andre Jackson's been playing
unbelievable been in a huge X Factor If
he if they get consistent scoring from
him then I think it's going to be a you
know it's it's going to be pretty
dominant for UConn what Tyler said
coming out from the West is so true I
mean Kansas was the one seed Arkansas
was one of those teams that you look at
the roster they have Pros but they have
young Pros yeah so they certainly ended
up in down season but the way they beat
Kansas and then the way Connecticut just
manhandled them you've got Gonzaga you
got UCLA I mean the West Was that was by
far the toughest region of the
tournament that Gonzaga UCLA game you
could just tell it took so much
emotional War it was so intense I also
think it's so funny I think about
UConn's early matchup against Iona I
remember when the bracket first came out
the storyline I heard was here's a Yukon
team that were worried about their guard
play against Iona and Rick Pitino I
heard a lot of people picking Iona in
the first round they were down at half
right one point I think they were down
one or two took a lead by one and they
were down by one it was right there and
then UConn went on the Run yeah
but it's funny how a oh that could be an
upset and now this team's here in the
final four in the the presiding favorite
to win it all Isaiah Wong I said this in
the in the break room I feel like he's
been playing college basketball for a
few years you guys heard that a lot who
are the other players names that you
think of for the man I feel like he's
been in college forever Harry Alice for
sure oh Perry Ellis is like the king
um Drew Timmy for me yeah it seems like
Drew Timmy's been there forever that's a
good one if you play The Freshman yes
then you get that label yeah that's true
all right 9-4 Miami finally getting some
points free throw line it's looking like
easy work for The Bigs of Uconn the
problem with omir is that he's so aware
that he can't get in foul trouble that I
think if they throw it into sunogo he'll
back off because he he can't get in foul
trouble Anthony Walker is six seven six
eight and he just doesn't have the size
to bang with sunogo or klingen yeah and
the thing is if omir does get in foul
trouble and would be curious to see if
Miami goes into some type of Zone
oh
so we're going to be getting uh Kendall
Walker in a little bit
do you think Yukon Alum are like other
Alum where it's like and he's like the
Yukon Alum crazy Pride do you think he
trash talks did he trash talk at all
when you guys were together about UConn
uh another one a lot of trash talking
with Kimba yeah I didn't know
actually wait no no never mind I was
gonna say I actually was eliminated by
Kemba Walker I was going to say in this
building but it was in Phoenix so he I
feel like he was one of those quiet
assassins he he never said much on the
court but his game spoke loudly yes yeah
he could really play Miami right now one
of nine from the floor Yukon four of
eight UConn holding on to a 11-4 lead we
are just over five and a half minutes
into this one and it feels like UConn
has a firm finger on the pulse of it
T3
that's an air ball we're going the other
way
Danny Hurley is not pleased
still waiting for that first Hurley in
this in the crowd shot
you guys both have in size playing
around what is it about sonogo's game
that that you guys really respect I mean
it's physically the fact that he can
step out and shoot from the perimeter he
protects the rim he's just he's a load
you know anybody he also moves well
enough to where he's not a liability
defensively he's just a really really
good player yeah all those and also he
scores really well around the rim he has
really good hands for a big so I think
it allows him to get some you know good
points and stuff around the rim but also
this clinging kid 32 for UConn yeah he
is a load too so I'm I'm glad to see him
in the game I'm curious to see what he
does
Miami hoisted up shots scrapping for
rebounds can't get anything to fall
right now UConn going the other way with
it
they go to the corner back out top deep
shot
jeez and here come the Huskies a 14-4
the Yukon fans are going nuts we talked
about more Miami fans in here but they
have nothing to cheer about right now
Miami is currently one for 11. UConn
five for ten
I mean Tristan Newton has really shot
the ball well over the last five games
from three he hasn't been good from
inside the arc but he is shot at a high
clip from the perimeter and he's such a
versatile piece all these Connecticut
has great versatility they can just have
they have a number of guys that can beat
you in a variety of ways and they can
play a number of ways so they Danny
Hurley the weapons that he's got at his
disposal are pretty impressive I think
it's so cool that we got a Hurley
in the final four yeah
that really is like some historic
basketball lineage
Miami looking for anything we got off
balance left-handers got a tweet Yukon
are men amongst boys that is what it
feels like
and we are getting closer to our 12
minute timeout where we are going to
welcome in the champ kembo Walker
man
Miami fans looking stressed
they'd like to see a ball go through the
hoops man
wow okay big stop there for Miami
[Applause]
I think they've just got to find a
rhythm for Wong Packer Miller just to
get some easy buckets to start trying to
to try and get their confidence and
momentum rolling because this is a
really good offense
their four guards are terrific and I
think the matchup to watch for me is
Jordan Miller and Alex Caravan just
because you're asking the Freshman to
guard to the dynamic playmaker Miller
didn't miss a shot first player since
Christian Laettner yeah to shoot over
seven times and also seven times from
the foul line hit them all made every
one of them unbelievable performance in
Kansas City
long falling back wow that's a tough
shot it's not an easy bucket though
that'll get your confidence going
Isaiah Wong knocking down the shot
what's up how are you doing good feel
and we're joined by someone that has hit
a lot of shots he is in a Yukon jacket a
Yukon hat those are Yukon pants with
Yukon colored Jays it is Kemba frickin
Walker cardiac Kemba in the house let's
go look what you walked into yes sir yes
sir big time do you have any doubt
about what this team nah nah the way
they've been playing how can you they
they got a complete team so much debt
like they have guys come off the bench
who can who can fill it up you know
someone is not playing well they can
come in and turn them up so hold on yeah
hey can we get a slow Zoom right here
please just a slow zoom on the Iced Out
husky that's sick I'm huskied out you
already know uh you like being in the
stadium I would imagine oh yeah brings
back good memories yeah it's like it's
it's like full circle right now it's
like a full so that's why I had to come
like share that emotion with us what
what happens when you pulled up to the
arena
um
I don't know it was they got to win it
okay okay they got to win no but for you
like for you for you to be back here for
me um it definitely brought back some
emotions just this is where I want it
you know what I mean so it's like every
time I come back to Houston even if I
don't play in this specific you know
Arena Stadium um it's always just that
certain feeling though like this is
where I won the National Championship so
it's a special place
let's take a look at the play here all
right so UConn Miami's making a little
surge right now
oh wow
this fell in a media row uh you know if
Twitter and Instagram was really popping
when you were doing your thing can you
imagine like the step back and what that
would have done I can't imagine I'm be
honest I can't imagine I'm glad it
wasn't as big either because I probably
would have had a big old head
um I don't know what I would have been
able to do with myself I mean this is
the play right here yeah hey man I put
hey you with Gary McGee if you're if you
ever told Gary I'm sorry no he has to
see this every Marsh man and he he was a
good player but the fact that you're a
part of that play yeah living infamy
Gary's that was my guy yeah to be honest
we was in Camp together like you know
like in the summertime like doing things
together like that but um yeah that was
unfortunate that was an unfortunate if
you're Jamie Dixon who's won a lot of
games on courts like this why are you
switching one through five yeah that's
what they did Gary in that spot that's
what they did back then you know but oh
man yeah that's that's what I'm known
for right now forget my whole NBA career
that's the play that shot that's that's
something touch Earth you hit a shot
it's crazy we had Marquis here earlier
put up 20 and 19 in the garden man and
now you're sitting here yep I just spoke
to him actually I just I'ma go see him
after this yeah that's that's a special
kid right there oh yeah he had a special
run so y'all were teammates huh Nancy
hands yes sir yes sir tell me about a
baby baby uh Ty baby
[Laughter]
T hands is
one of the most competitive
Paul working dudes I ever been around to
be honest and he's a great teammate man
like you know he stuff fuels you yeah
those are the kind of guys you need you
need guys like that around like
obviously he's older than me so you know
like I watch and I watch you know oh you
were the baby I was a baby baby Kemba
like yeah hey Kimball was as competitive
as they come he he's earned everything
he's got he was a hard worker too I love
playing with him I actually our team in
Charlotte we're about as close as you
get that was a great team I agree my
shorts stay there but Cleveland's done
big things for Charlotte so I was
honored to be his teammate but uh Kim I
got a question for you is UConn a blue
blood we had this to build a question no
question like I'm gonna be real like
it's about time that we are talked about
you know with that kind of respect you
know what I mean like we need to be
talking about what the Dukes in the uncs
like coach Calhoun's name needs to be
thrown out there some more like he he
started all this he created all this
like we up there like is another final
four for us if you guys win it this year
there'll be three national championships
one from UConn by three different
coaches wow so that would be considered
a blue blood to me and also the past
three national championships have come
from the state of Texas so if there's
some good energy and some luck that
might be yeah I hope so but you guys
don't need it look like the most
dominant team in the final four right
yeah the whole tournament we're looking
like it but you know you got to finish
it off you know yeah man March Madness
this year has been unbelievable man like
since it's been it's been the one of the
greatest I've ever seen like I'm I've
been such a fan of all these teams
because your team was an underdog do you
think it makes you root for the underdog
in March Madness more question no
question I mean everybody Tyler was like
I like my number one season he's going
yeah
achieve the beat oh yeah AJ probably
yeah my freshman year early family oh
there you go early family
playing on teams that were not
I like this blue blood conversation
though that's good especially because
when you think about like UConn like
since 1999 like that's some serious
numbers oh yeah I would say they're
they're relevant I mean they're on the
verge of winning their fifth National
Championship yep so there's something to
be said wow no question
Miami's starting to heat up deficit cut
to five take a look at the replay of
this reverse layup heck of a move by the
Hurricanes that was tough dang yeah that
was tough time did you catch that game
winner in the last game I did I actually
just saw the kid when I was walking up
here actually that was tough
his form was perfect oh man
you know what it's like hitting those
shots at the end of the game a little
bit a little bit do you do you have a
sense of the clock or oh yeah yeah no
question like my whole thing is against
that spot so I could get my shot off and
know the balls I'm trying to get the
ball in the air so it won't be no more
time left if you want it you want to
hear it yeah damn yeah I'm trying to end
the whole thing
is there a particular spot on the court
um hear that right at that free throw
yeah that that left side of that or that
free throw line for sure yeah I'm trying
to get there trying to get to the
mid-range it depends though are you
getting to the left side because the
footwork is easier as a right-handed
player no that was my move no going
against that that left step back you
know um I'm really just trying to see
what the defense is giving me to be
honest but um if I can get to that step
back create some space yeah I would
definitely love that what was the best
part of playing for Jim Calhoun oh man I
think I think the best part playing for
coach was
how much he challenged me how much he
challenged me like since from the first
day I got there to the day I left man
like he challenged me so much to become
a leader
um a better player and just an overall
man you know what I mean so yeah he
he yelled at me like it didn't matter it
didn't matter like you know I mean he's
so competitive he was so Fierce like I
loved I loved every moment of it loved
every moment of it
Miami was in the midst of a 9-2 run
since uh Kemba sat down I was getting
nervous big play there by sunogo already
has 10 points 18-13 Miami wasn't going
to take this and just come on out get
out of there they're too Dynamic
huge huge like we passed them in the
tunnel and we were stunned yeah every
dude is like six ten all these kids are
huge nowadays man it's ridiculous
well maybe I'm just small yeah you and
Marquis
yeah
so when UConn's playing when you're at
home what's the setup
man it depends on where I'm at but I'm
just on the couch and I'm locked in you
have family around you friends around
you oh just my girl just my girl just my
girl but usually she she goes in the
room or something like that because you
know I'm like I might be a little bit
too intense sometimes yeah with the
Eagles yeah I'm a little bit too intense
so she's like let me get out of here let
me watch it now oh wow
big play by Miami the chemist here I'm
like rooting for you yeah let's go
Miami's a little bit undersized but
they're getting to the offensive glass
here they go hard they go hard
they go hard shout out to my boy Duran
Scott man we we got a little back going
right now I need my Huskies to get this
W where's Durant playing now Durant is
actually he just got to Spain actually
like a few like like last week has he
been has he been overseas for most days
um for most his career yes sir yes sir
yeah yep yep
that's got to be fun yeah yeah where did
you play overseas I was in Spain my
rookie year I played for Georgia
Armani's team and Milan and then I
played in Moscow my last year and that
broke me like I told my agent get me
back on an NBA roster or I'm retiring
because I cannot go back over here how
are the jerseys on the Giorgio Armani
there are money he'd say Courtside you
had to chase oh wow we were talking
about this three models he'd bring
actors he'd bring all it was it was like
it was like the equivalent of playing
for the Lakers in the Italian league and
you would have all these Milan
celebrities like you know wow famous
chefs and famous TV people and all that
stuff so that's awesome
the energy in this stadium has moved to
Miami
they have a lot more fans than y'all I
know I heard that early when I first got
here take a look stand up and go over
there I see I see the colors yeah but
this is this is what we do you know what
I mean like this is what we do we doubt
nothing we don't need the fans we don't
need all the fans and stuff like that
they don't believe in us we know who we
got here God did
[Applause]
uh we know who we got here we good
that is crazy Tyler was saying this
earlier like three coaches going for the
third title yep that just shows the
program yes in a special place special
place stores Connecticut
it's cold it's snowing what else we got
to do be in the gym be in the gym that's
it
how's your body feel when during this
time yeah like playing well I feel
pretty good are you good yeah I'm
feeling pretty good I mean I'm I'm
working every day you know trying to get
stronger every single day so yeah no
complaints on my end that's good then
your knee had been yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah I'm working on it
though you know yep getting it right
trying to stay ready
look at this girl
and Miami has tied it up at 19. right as
we get to the eight minute timeout
groundbound ask Kemba does Connecticut
have better Pizza than New York no way
come on now who asked that ground bounce
that's an awful question man sorry it's
okay no we didn't I love Connecticut I
love Connecticut but New York best piece
in the world what's the spot it don't
matter and he walked to Any Corner Joe's
walk to Any Corner okay literally let's
see if you say the same thing as Marquis
best chopped cheese best chopped cheese
uh dirty kitchen oh yeah dirty kitchen
it's called Dirty kitchen
this was in Harlem too all right let's
see what other we got for tweets right
now uh don Marcus said oh let's see
Shabazz Napier's mom who is here with
Kemba Walker's mom just led the Yukon
hustle oh yeah I know I was just with
them yeah they they are outrageous yeah
so the moms are even crazier bro like so
now you know this is like the first time
I'm really like
in the stands like at the UConn game so
now I'm seeing what my mom was doing
while I was playing and I'm looking at
her like this lady is crazy like her
answer badges man ain't Carmen they're
gone they're going crazy on there what's
crazy to you what did you not expect to
see from your life
they're not being quiet
like little people's faces No not
nobody's face but like it's people below
them and they are they screaming like at
the top of their lungs like
real fans I would think it could have
only been worse when you were playing
better I'm glad I'm glad I was on the
court I'll tell you that much
man
what do you uh what do you think about
having a Hurley as your coach Hurley and
just the the lineage that it is yeah oh
I mean I actually played against those
guys in high school and stuff like that
I mean I would have loved it obviously I
mean his energy is impeccable you know
what I mean his energy is it's Second To
None man what what kid won't love that
you know what I mean well I haven't
really got a chance to be close to him
but there are some kids from afar yeah
if I'm afar I mean I could tell he's an
amazing amazing guy amazing coach so
yeah is it different when it's not your
head coach is that and I know Tyler
you've dealt with this too when your guy
retires it's just it's a different feel
yeah it is yeah no not for me I mean
obviously like it's like you said my guy
coach Calhoun he's not coaching but no
it's no different I mean UConn is still
UConn yeah I mean
yeah North Carolina didn't change I was
a little worried about that but uh he
lives in Hubert yeah great job very
welcoming yeah uh is Calhoun still
around UConn a lot yes yes yes yes he'll
never leave that place we love it that's
good he love it man he actually just
spoke to those guys a few weeks ago I
seen him on a post someone sent it to
somebody sent to me um that dude was
amazing man he loves basketball I gotta
ask you I played with Jeff Adrian in
Minnesota
and one time Glenn Robinson III asked
him Jeff what is your nickname and he
goes my nickname is 40. is that true and
let me tell you why he goes my nickname
is 40 because I can give you 40 on any
night and we're like 40 rebounds no
disrespected Jeff because he was a beast
yeah I mean we didn't call him that in
college I was gonna say 40 was not what
I wanted but he was a beast though oh my
goodness that dude was unbelievable he
would crush you on the glass he was a
good fit alongside you you had uh it's
Stanley Robinson and at the beat and but
40. yeah we're all like
[Applause]
40. I don't think anybody
Yukon 53 Butler 41. I mean look at what
they had to do the video they didn't
like squeeze it because the quality is
awful that's not sure okay oh man
amazing you're gonna buy this on Blu-ray
it makes me feel old for sure I feel old
too yeah that's ridiculous you guys held
a team to 41 points oh we were terrible
too we were terrible too I was
honestly I was I was tired oh wow that
night I mean we that was the 11th game
you know we won the Big East tournament
it was right a lot of basketball so we
got the dub though we got the dub that's
all that really matters did you play in
the six overtime game I did that's my
question honesty
[Applause]
I was exhausted I was a freshman that's
one of the hardest games I ever played
in my entire basketball amazing college
basketball yeah that really was so I
went to Syracuse and that was my first
year after I graduated and I was getting
paid eighteen thousand dollars as a
reporter in Hastings Nebraska so I'm
watching that game and everybody's like
who cares and I'm like living and dying
Eric dievendorf Paul Harris Johnny Flynn
yep that was an amazing I thought Johnny
Flynn was going to be Kemba Walker I
mean I really did bro that was the guy I
looked up to as well
Niagara Falls I mean that dude say one
more time that dude is unbelievable
um healthy yeah that's the only thing
yeah he would just I think he got some
hip issues that stuff was really bad
yeah I love Johnny Johnny playing was
unbelievable his pick and roll game man
unreal did they ever play him alongside
scoop did scoop Jardine player did they
um not really yeah
I think school was actually hurt that
yeah
all right I have two chat questions for
Kemba
Jeremy Levin who's a producer kembo why
the red I thought Yukon was blue come on
now we got you know I know you see the
red in the Jersey you know it's an
accent color yeah you know just a little
match just matching a little bit Johnny
Benson asked Kemba how did Michael
Jordan motivate your game
I mean that's MJ you know what I mean
like
I think anybody who plays for MJ is
already motivated well for me was the
fact that you know everybody around the
organization always told me that he was
the one who really wanted to trade up
for me in the draft
um like he made that decision by himself
you know what I mean so I didn't want to
let him down that's what it was for me
so yeah I just grinding crazy to hear
coming into the NBA and MJ's like I want
that guy yep yep that was unbelievable
to be honest so for me I'm like I'm not
letting him down I would not let him
down I'm a grind I'm gonna continue to
get better and he allowed me to you know
he allowed me to grow that was that was
the biggest thing you had space your
time yeah he allowed that so you guys
ever see him come out and play MJ did he
ever he never know it was by that time
yeah yeah he was done anything else for
your former teammate before I send him
off t
now I'm pulled for UConn yes sir I'd
like to hear that tournament so I like
to hear that I'm Gonna Roll with you
guys all right come up 25-19 Yukon right
now how does this game end what is the
final score final score
I'm gonna go
55 yeah it might be a low scoring one
okay
55-47 I'm gonna go I hope you can't win
but at the end of the day I don't really
care I just want my guys to win that's
it so I could be back here on Monday one
of the best to ever do it 45. truly a
joy to watch we've enjoyed watching you
forever man and you're one of the best
dudes there ever I appreciate it Kevin
Walker thank you congrats on everything
good luck with UConn the rest of the
week thank you Matt appreciate it thanks
for having me yep and uh you can get up
whenever all right bet all right fellas
great seeing you brother
take care of Kimbo hey W you're good to
see you man you too Miami had some runs
there while Kemba was here
I do like that jacket though that is
clean the Husky on the back and you were
hating on the red no that was a that was
somebody else's name Jeremy Jeremy we
call them all hater Jeremy
he didn't like that the accent color had
become the main color huh
you know what's crazy
just to see how big he is in person and
to think about what he did on the court
that's crazy oh yeah like I just keep
thinking about being down there and then
like staying the next to y'all and then
thinking about what I like I'm just I
was like looking at his kneecaps but the
way he could go he had burst he would
get by people he could create like that
Gary McGee clip he creates four feet on
the step I mean he is creating so much
space Oh Yeah
now that was crazy
good dude too great guard
all right UConn is now up eight Tyler
even watching oh yeah I've been watching
all right so what's the what's the Tyler
hansborough read
well we knew this one last Miami uh with
their backcourt going on this drought a
little bit but like I said clinging
you're not coming in his Lane he's got
too much size too big to shoot over kind
of reminds me a little bit of uh
Kessler uh Kessler Walker from Auburn
yeah he went to UNC for a year then he
transferred but uh also Jordan Hawkins
he hit that three and has been
non-existent yeah he's got to get in
this game he's got to get involved
somehow and they've got to get sunogo
going as well I'd like to get those two
guys some touches
Yukon it was tied 19-19 UConn goes on an
8-0 run and while the points are good
their defense seems to be the thing
that's ratcheting up right now
[Applause]
when you've got the rim protection
though I mean you think you've got an
easy basket there your Nigel pack yeah
and Klingon packs in the stands I mean
it's just it frees your perimeter
defense so much you can pressure you can
gamble a little bit because you know you
got the Big Fellas behind you and
they're cleaning everything up is that
Hawkins right there he looks very ill he
looks exhausted you got a guy next to
him that looks like a doctor yeah and
he's over here like
you know when you don't feel so good
that like sweat feels painful yeah and
like that's what he he's like leaning on
the guy right now
I mean he looks like he could throw up
yo he does he looks like a throw right
now visibly ill
yeah some guys when they're injured or
they're playing they're playing sick it
takes their mind off the game and so
that allows them to not even think about
play some guys can play better the
Jordan game uh when he got sick everyone
thinks when they get sick I'm gonna have
a Jordan game
it also shows me it works like yeah give
me the flu so I can move
but it shows the human aspect too you
know the guy's dealing with a an illness
and the impact that can have on you also
fatigue plays a factor making sure
you're getting liquids all this stuff he
may not have his legs I just always feel
so bad I think about a guy like him
who's had a great run he wants to have
his Kemba moment right and then he wakes
up one day and his throat hurts and
you're like you got to be kidding me
that's the most outstanding player in
the West Regional right there yeah he
was balling
and then he goes home and like you're
just thinking of every hand you shook
every door you open the bad every
Starbucks Barista that like sniffled
when they gave you your coffee oh and
you hate all of them stuff I never
thought about that until kovid but yeah
I mean that'll change your brain with
that yeah yeah seriously man
all right so UConn started off super hot
Miami battled back and now we're sitting
Miami sort of in this Yukon I love I
just keep thinking that Walker Kessler
comparison is perfect it is
and what he's doing with Utah this year
yeah I don't think he moves as well as
Walker Kessler just to be honest I think
Walker Kessler's got better footwork but
klingen has that type of size oh yeah
and just having that size and Link and
he's not a total stiff like he can move
a little bit and having that just
changes everything around the rim it
allows you to to dominate the boards and
then also change shots which is a huge
deal
I feel like also the the job they've
done the defensive glass here over the
last
four minute segment has improved whereas
Miami was flying in there initially
stealing possessions and now UConn's not
just getting stopped but they're
shutting this down
you're right Miami was getting a lot of
points off turnovers and now UConn's
keep more prepared of the ball
we're watching putting on the television
I'm not sure oh it's Grand it's Grant
Hill do you think they're having Jim
Nance to the Masters call is that what's
happening probably
I think it was oh look who it is
how are you uh speaking of Uconn
um the Huskies now of eight we just had
camba and now we are having uh a person
who had equal success Renee Montgomery
joining us on the show right now I'm in
here we're in the building what's up
we're not usually away from Atlanta can
I just ask how do we feel right now as a
husky oh okay so confident how like I do
feel confident I mean I think that
winning by such a large margin coming in
this game my whole thing I've been
talking about is we can't read our own
press clippings like just stay locked in
obviously Jordan Hawkins put a little
wrench in things if you were just
looking at him he's looking sick sick
yeah oh like because I was making my way
to you guys so I've you know I haven't
seen a lot of they just showed him and
he was like leaning on a doctor oh for
real but you guys are so big that like
yeah I mean it's tough too because when
you have a stomach problem that's your
core so I was concerned that even if he
gets back even if he figures it out and
gets on the court you know what happens
exactly when your core is gone it's like
the worst so Renee comes and the tweets
start coming in so let's see what we got
on the old Twitter machine here at final
four live my heart is full after a visit
with royalty oh wait is that Jonathan
pulled up one set wasn't me this morning
we did a pregame show tonight a kid's
husky is named Jonathan yes Jonathan the
Husky I thought he wasn't making the
trip Delta actually flew him out
special dogs
time out how did it become Jonathan
that's what his mama named him his mama
called him Jonathan I'ma call him
Jonathan what you mean I thought it'd be
all houndy the Husky or something like
that
Jonathan this team though all year I
know you've been keeping an eye on him
yep what do you think from basketball
perspective what have you thought of
them all year Well I hosted the first
night which you know the open practice
it was the men and women together yeah
so I talked to Dan Hurley and I was like
how you feeling like I'll be going to
CBS we'll be talking a lot of noise in
the studio yeah what they make me look
good so today I just dapped them up and
I was like boy I've been insufferable in
the studio but I just think we have a
good combination he told you from the
beginning they're going to be a problem
he said I think we'll be all right you
know coaches don't ever give you too
much so I'll read between the lines of
that but I mean honestly it's not just
our office a lot of people talk about
how we dominate and the pain and we have
Jordan Hawkins the top prospect in the
NBA but really it's our defense that I
think kind of get flies under the radar
of what we do to teams that are look I
mean Miami's the best offensive team
left in the final four right now and
there's seven of 30 from the field boom
Yukon and they haven't scored in the
last four minutes and 22 seconds of
Uconn so Tyler picked Yukon before the
tournament to win it all three
tournament and tonight he's been
predicting everything he predicted a lot
of the first he even said Prayer by the
way he said I think Butler's gonna hit a
game winner
um
at halftime he was like Butler game
winner yeah
I wish what's it been like though y'all
been enjoying it oh yeah in the
conversation to be honest to be in the
stadium yeah and to feel them chills
just like
it's so different from just Pros like
you know like we pretty much cover Pros
on a normal basis so when you get around
college sports and college fans there's
like just this different ways I've never
been to a Cavs game where I've seen a
dude with a visor like like into the
camera you don't get that in the pool
don't get them kind of uh oh you get to
tease Boo in the home team sometimes
they get tired of folks
all right Miami got the bucket there so
that was their first Basket in almost
five minutes
UConn now this is almost life post
Hawkins so who do they go to now with
Hawkins maybe Sidelines I mean that's
the thing about this team is that you
can move Tristan Newton to that deal you
got nahim Ali I mean you have so many
weapons that's the thing that's
impressive about UConn is even though
you're talking about losing a guy yeah
who's the most outstanding player of the
West Regional not that they're gonna
replace what he does because he's an
elite shooter you do have guys that you
can throw out there even if it's
calcaterra and you can feel good right
about what they're gonna give you
because they go nine and ten deep and
calcaterra's do a big game or a good
game absolutely honestly I mean Jordan
Hawkins has been the main one that's
been pretty much lighting it up
I think he scored 44 points in the last
two games so was on fire open look
there's a lien right there oh let's try
to make it on board right into his chest
right into his chest
uh last night I was with Candace and we
were watching Iowa South Carolina
and it was an entire bar going nuts
listen and that was really cool my whole
timeline and I'm talking about like not
people that avidly followed women's
basketball because a lot of those people
are my timeline but I'm talking about
random people comedians just casual fans
want to see what she can do it's great
for the women's game tough though that
was my fear South Carolina going
undefeated in the tournament my senior
year we went into the tournament
undefeated so it's never going to matter
unless we win so we ended up obviously
winning but I feel bad for the seniors
so there was a part of you that was like
I don't want South Carolina to do what
we did no one of them
you lose might be the game that kicks
you out the tournament and nobody cares
that you went undefeated to that point
do you put Caitlyn Clark in the in the
shop Upper Echelon with like super Diana
Taurasi Candace Parker shamiqua holds is
she is she entering that discussion
she's yeah she's entering the discussion
discussion but it's like people like
Maya Moore I played with her in college
oh man I played with her in the
she might be one of the best players
I've ever yeah and Maya would be there
too I mean but and it's also too I
consider winning to be a factor in
greatness so if everywhere you go you
win you're a great you're amazing and so
I think that the Maya Moore's the Diana
taurasis of the world they've won a lot
of championships in their life so
Caitlin Clark is starting though I mean
to bring her team right now to the
championship game you're right she's
starting the conversation if she does
another 30 40 and knocks off the whole
thing she's in the conversation yeah
gotta win I agree yeah you got to win
and you know and that's what I mean by
it's like it's a journey so I've watched
these people over a career dude yeah so
I'm going to be a little bit stingy with
throwing people in that conversation in
someone's life work but she's definitely
starting the conversation for sure
you're like Ty you're we're not calling
you a grater of blue blood until you win
all the time you have to yeah you gotta
win you gotta win yeah everybody can be
great in spurts right like I mean we've
seen teams now that aren't in the
tournament be great in Spurs but who's
been great all season long you have
teams like FAU who won 35 games this
season we were 35-0 but we won a
championship that's enough games to win
wow what year was that 350 2009 yes did
you play with Kathy Kearns check Twitter
she's my class yeah that's crazy small
world yeah so the UConn Huskies man oh
yeah this is what out this is what you
said I was talking about so yeah Asia
Wilson you know got in on the post and
talked about it because I mean that's a
real fear you don't go in the game
scared but you know now there's no room
for error
there is no room for era for Jim
larenega and the hurricanes only 24
points for one of the top 10 ranked
offenses in college basketball the UConn
defense is putting the clamps down 34 to
24 Huskies
I don't want to get too overconfident
right now because FAU was up 14. and
because Miami light he likes to be the
underdog so I feel like everything about
this moment they're really enjoying so
I'm not and
just saw like you said a buzzer beater
that Tyler called
Butler made a buzzer beater they were
down 14 in the second half like come on
now remember two the Texas game I think
Texas was up 13 or 14 on Miami so it's
so no I'm comfortable but I'm not like
content yeah you're right Texas was up a
lot
[Applause]
huh this is a nice setup though yeah you
like the chairs it's a little sexy up
here with the red leather we do have a
comment that said the red couches are
fire the only problem is is that my legs
get really sweaty and so I think when I
stand up I look like I peed in my pants
I did it earlier yeah my wife says my
cheeks were chicken they call that
swampus
they emphasize the a more there it is
this is a family show all right 10
seconds left Yukon can they go deeper
into double digits they get it down to
clinging oh Baseline Drive oh give it to
me good luck
[Applause]
wow from downtown Jordan Hawk is not
there his teammates is like I got you I
think they ran a hammer action and then
he just switched onto Hawkins and left
him open wow they did but that's just
bad like bad Communications they had two
players on one he said come on you can
already see the player look didn't even
run out oh man he held that hand up
that's a great pass it's a really good
pass by Tristan Newton
Yukon oh it's just me up here when you
go oh okay well you know what else
getting into Jonathan the Husky is uh
weighing in as well Jonathan Houston
such a beautiful city oh my God so his
name is John
and he's out here tweeting look he's
Jonathan though what is that 10 11 the
14th the 14th what's in the 14 so it's a
family name it's a tradition yeah I want
to know how long Jonathan why was it the
initial ones
who named him Jonathan initially he was
probably a Twitter poll presented by
Wendy's
yeah see what you did there uh Dan
Hurley uh Renee what's up what's up it
do you like frosties oh yeah the vanilla
vanilla or chocolate vanilla that's your
favorite yeah you you eat them yes
yes
could you imagine uh no they were gonna
come out of this as we say goodbye
and they did to uh Jamal Crawford things
come out that's true no but what I have
for you is a Parting Gift what's that
for the from the good people of Wendy's
what is it this is a year's supply of
free frosties
I'm not lying they're zooming on her
face look how excited she is because we
just had this conversation of what does
a year Supply mean can I go every day
three times a day and get it all the
time or is it like one free Frosty per
transaction per visit wow at restaurant
every time
this is like the keys
get
the frosty in the whip got the frosty in
the whip
do you see what Wendy's does to them
I like free stuff man I'm just saying
free stuff and freestyling I appreciate
it Renee it's always great to see you
here congrats on the first half thank
you good luck the rest of the week let's
get it thank you like your breakdowns
man you know what's funny they gave me
the frosties and I just was like I'm
just gonna give it to people as they
leave so happy it really has brought
great job man all right speaking of
Wendy's we're squareing up presented by
Wendy's Isaiah Wong a lot of hype coming
into this game he's a minus 18. one of
six from the floor just Five Points
Adama sunogo shocked us all with those
two threes the beginning of the game and
then since then has been pounding the
boards 13-5 thus far for Adama sunogo
pretty heck of a good start
need him to get four more boards though
because I picked them to go over eight
uh well yeah four more so
the thing is somebody's gonna have to
step up for UConn uh with Jordan Hawkins
being sick so I'll be curious who that
is maybe Andre Jackson he's done a lot
for him in the tournament I can see him
doing some things but somebody else can
have to step up besides uh sunogo I'm
feeling good about my picks to click or
whatever they were gone was uh
sunogo over 17. okay so go 10 rebounds
was it uh over eight I think over right
we need to well you're right there bro
stance out here and I think we've only
seen the Hurley's once so I'm a little
bit worried about that one yeah you need
you need four more yep
oh
all right so I had UConn winning by five
that feels good need more Hurley
cutaways Robbie you come by seven
feeling great so no go feeling really
good points and he's great Tyler needs
three more rebounds and omir how many
rebounds so Mira has only got three
beautiful
that was the game that we needed to bet
a lot I'm not a big fan of picking under
but sometimes you got to do it based on
matchups and size so that's that's why I
went there the Ender is tough because
you have to root for people to play
poorly yeah I didn't like that it's not
funny so I I think about unders
differently how so I don't think of them
rooting for failure
I think sometimes maybe Vegas gave them
a bad number that maybe was a little bit
or you're actually betting against the
public so let's say let's say uh who was
the Miami kid that did not miss a shot
Jordan Miller and let's say everyone's
going oh I think Jordan Miller's going
to kill it again and you go I think he's
going to come back to normal a little
bit if it's too high it's not Jordan
Miller's fault I'm not rooting against
Jordan Miller I just think for him
no I'm not no when he misses I do cheer
you're not rooting yeah that's right
that's true you can't root for everybody
it's like shorting a stock yeah exactly
that's what you're doing you're shorting
Jordan Miller 100 or Jordan Hawkins or
whoever we want to talk about with that
all right first half highlights taking a
look UConn jumped out to that really big
lead Miami came roaring back transition
fast break turnovers they ended up tying
this one at 19. this was a huge play
what's really funny is Miami made the
run when Kemba was here and as soon as
he left
UConn went on a run so we were tied at
19 then UConn went on a run an 8-0 run
where Miami didn't score again this is
the last Miami points and then it was
all UConn after that
wait what a pass I mean they're trapping
that ball screen at half court and to
throw that into klingen it's a long pass
but to have enough on it pretty
impressive stuff you know what I like
from sunogo when he gets the ball to
post he doesn't dribble it he keeps it
up and he finishes
he's just he's a fundamentally sound guy
it's also getting good position in the
paint putting yourself in that position
first yeah which is a huge deal doing
your work early getting position in the
paint where you don't have to put the
ball on the floor and you can go right
up and you also avoid a double team
which is big for a player like Kim who's
going to draw a lot of attention from
the defense I like that phrase do your
work early oh yeah you hear that you
hear that sound when you uh when you
play basketball that's that's the common
one I want to say some people don't
think I'm nuts I was watching the wrong
TV during one of the highlights so when
I said that was an amazing pass not
actually on the screen that everyone at
home watched so that's oh that's I'm not
losing my mind I'm watching the CBS feed
and didn't realize that I was yeah we're
both showing highlights at the same time
Yukon up
37-24 that three at the end that was a
big big swing motivation momentum wise
Miami's hitting one out of every four
shots UConn one out of every two shots
this is kind of what how we thought this
was good kind of
I don't know do you think it would be
like this this is how they played even
without Hawkins they're so complete
they're just such a good team on both
ends yeah that's right you can't explain
they've been dominant but also Miami's
shooting 25 from the field yeah it's not
good and they're backcourt's much more
talented than that and they're a better
team I don't think that's sustainable so
I do see Miami this really happen
tonight
oh look at this look at the high knees
on the rest he always does he's known
for that yeah that's his thing that's
what he does not every game
why I'm not sure I've always wondered
too keeping the hammies calisthenics
did you look at what o'meara's got
rebound wise three all right so you're
in good shape then I don't know I don't
want to feel too good about that one I
love it y'all are
never I love them we're too low
[Applause]
oh or what are the uh high level
analytics telling you
well
[Applause]
since we're on the socials I'm just
checking the socials the turnovers for
UConn were Killers that's how Miami got
back in the game seven turnovers Miami
capitalized for seven points the
offensive glass has been a big thing
kind of surprisingly Miami is what are
they like in the 75th
75-76 range in terms of offensive
rebound percentage for uh for all of
college basketball so for them with
their you know limited size going up
against the gray rebounding Yukon team
they they have really gone but your
guards have got to block out when you're
playing Miami it's not just omir those
other guys are flying in there but
that's really been Miami's only offense
points off turnovers getting out in the
open court and then living on the
offensive glass
you're right seven of their 24 were off
turnovers that's nearly 30 percent of
their point and they've got seven how
about this guys I got my name on the
screen let's go what do we think what do
we think also Tyler I also just go by
lefco
all right so you can tell people you're
like I was working with this douche
lefco to say that no don't say Adam only
Left Coast all right
um
all right
second half
what can Miami do other than make shots
is there anything defensively to handle
the size of Yukon
I mean you're probably gonna see some
post-traps with sunogo I think just
because he's so overwhelming
um
they've got to flip to match up you know
they've got to make what is that they
got to make him guard on the perimeter
they've got to drive him they've got to
find ways to to make him work
defensively and and also bring both him
and Klingon outside that pain because
they're sitting back there and they're a
great deterrent from driving the ball
they make it really hard for your guards
to get in there and then get any type of
easy basket because they're the way they
block shots yeah I'm with Robbie on this
also sunogos hit two three-pointers
which is maybe a little uncharacteristic
for him unexpected uh but I would put
him in ball screens just like he said
bring them out make them guard uh he he
does lack a little lateral quickness so
I think he could be find some
vulnerabilities in that but also you're
gonna have to control sonogo because he
is their dominant scorer and Jordan
Hawkins being sick they're going to go
to snow go I think more and if you're
running an action maybe you Tire him out
a little bit for the offensive end uh to
the chat Don Marcus saying sunogo doing
Prime Ray Allen things I own NYC saying
Wong gonna have to bring the heat lucky
Pablo adding the depth of Yukon is
overwhelming so far God five King Yukon
is too big for the U and Mr Perfect
disaster first half for Miami being only
down 13 is a win for them
we said that in the first game yeah
being only down seven was a win
I don't know if this feels the same the
San Diego State being down seven felt
different than Miami being down 13. no I
agree but I I I'm confident saying that
learning is given the same speech we're
down 13. we were down 13 against Texas
we could be down 20. yeah we have played
so poorly offensively but at what number
do we stop saying it always feels like a
win oh we're down 20. it feels like a
win yeah I wouldn't feel good about this
coach but that's what I'd be telling my
team I think he's gonna make some
adjustments but UConn's the most
dominant team you cannot be down this
much going into half you've got to
figure something out and it's got to be
from the backcourt Wong's got to get his
confidence going he's got to shoot
better from the floor if they want to
have a chance they're gonna have to have
a couple players get hot and a couple
players for UConn to kind of go cold
cold they can't have snow go dominate
the game if they want to stay in it I
looked up with sunogo averages from a
makes an attempt standpoint from three
this year he averages 0.5 lakes and 1.33
is attempted per game so for him to make
two probably a career high for him to
make two in the first four minutes and
they told Amir they just backed off
they're letting him shoot yeah and
that's where those coaches as a player
you're looking at your coach like that's
on you dude yeah because you told us
stat wise let's see what Miami is coming
in with so it is our first ever final
four appearance which Jim Lauren Diego
Lara niega have we been saying it wrong
I don't get Flareon that's an Enya yeah
uh he had that incredible run when he
led the 11 seed George Mason to final
four in 2006. Miami has never faced
UConn or San Diego State in the NCAA
tournament
he'll if look if he leads to come back
here
he might go down as one of the goats I
didn't realize that
larenick has been in Miami this entire
time
to go from George Mason to be here and
for this to kind of be full circle I
don't know why I assume that laronega
was other places I just I feel like
they've had some good teams I mean with
Shane Larkin oh yeah Lonnie Walker I
mean they went to uh the lead eight last
year Miami they're one win from the
final four so this is an experienced
team uh he's done a good job he's went
to the portal got some good guys so uh
yeah I mean he's he's done a great job
at Miami it's interesting to watch the
offensive sets of this game compared to
what we watched in the last game last
game we're going oh dribble handoff
dribble handoff then you see what UConn
runs and you're like oh this is they got
five different options on this play
UConn's profile it is a lot more stacked
than any other team in this Final Four
history accomplishments 36 NCAA
tournament sixth final four appearance
and the most titles since 1999
Tyler I think there are Blue Bloods yep
I mean you you can make that argument
they've got a great case
um and I think their color is blue
Duke North Carolina Kansas
they're they're all wearing blue it's
not the best looking blue but then it is
blue
how much of your home is North Carolina
none none listen you surround yourself
every time you're in Chapel Hill that's
that's the only color you see you can
only take so much of it it is the best
color in the world no questions we have
the best uniforms yes best looking
uniforms uh but yeah you know that might
be a little too much to do the walls and
take it home with me
how sweet was it wearing that Jersey
it's the best Jersey I mean yeah the uh
like the first time you went to your
locker and saw it hanging up
uh when was it it would have been our
first road game but I like the uh the
white Carolina blue but they're all blue
the old school yeah just like those two
uniforms nothing beats that's the one
with the design down the side
oh yeah did it ever overwhelm you when
you look to the one end and see like the
banners of people who had been first
team all-americans there because I think
that could be where you'd see that and
just think oh my God I like the pound
that's been through I mean it's it's
amazing even if you look like when you
see you know the people have been real
important like Phil Ford to me is the
best Tar Heels ever and you know you see
his jersey you see Jordan Jameson
Stackhouse yeah you know a list of
Rasheed walls all these guys and it's
just a lot of tradition and uh yeah I
mean it's we got I mean it's it's
unbelievable a tradition that I thought
you were gonna start that was gonna last
forever was a little game of Texas ping
pong
or if you don't know the rules if you
get beat two points in a row we're gonna
need you to lift up your shirt and take
one right off the stomach this is a
video clip that I have seen a million
times in my life and I think we need to
relive this right now so Tyler Hasbro
for the oh you gotta be kidding
I like to get a little run you cannot
hit the ball past the net that's the
only thing and you also cannot Flinch
that's my roommate Bobby Frazier Bobby
Frazier he's not in that type of shape
right now it hasn't touched away but
yeah he took that one right off the
chest it's just uh what happens when you
lose did anybody do it where they throw
it up like a tennis serve or is it more
so bouncing in is the play I think it's
the bounce and also you get a little
momentum to run step in and you get a
little more accuracy the closer you get
I think throwing it up may limit because
you could lose I mean if you have a bad
toss like a tennis serve
you're trying to track it you're ruining
your opportunity you can send them a lot
like a little soft shot which isn't that
painful what you want to do is you want
that ball to hit the skin make it kind
of Sting so you want to put a lot of
yeah get the skin a little puffy maximum
damage yeah like a paintball yeah yeah
it's a great comparison see I know that
we would play and then I would get he
would hit me like seven times and then
I'd finally get one and I would try and
kill it and I would miss like that's a
garage it's taking Carnage and damage
I'm like covered like I got hit like by
a hornet's nest and I'm messing him oh
that's the most frustrating thing is
when you win and then you just miss just
with it you know and I'm a little bit
upset with our producer because that was
they she even wrote in the chat we have
the hansborough Ping Pong video when
you're ready and that was just me
getting set up so thank you that was
great uh 13-point lead for UConn
four minutes left at halftime
and we're joined we're going to be
joined
by a man wow
this is a strong Jersey it almost might
be a hockey jersey
Lonnie dot Walker in the building all
right let's get right into it we're down
13. uh-huh do we still have hope how we
feeling oh you know oh he's uh he's
upset the game's all about runs you know
you know and especially this is our
first time being in this predicament
especially in the final four
um you know you gotta get them Jitters
out you know I know there's there's a
couple key open shots that we don't miss
and everything so you know that's well
as you know you know the game's all
about runs yes so I think you know a lot
of players if we didn't play well the
first half usually that second half you
tend to turn it up and be like all right
you guys were down to Texas big came
back came back that's what we do we
always the underdog so we you know we we
carry that on our back consistently I
like how confident you are because we're
over here being like man you kind of
look all right
I'll let y'all talk that talk yeah yeah
you know just talk to me after the game
no we will we're gonna see if your
energy can help turn it a little bit
because we have had a lot of Uconn in
the first half uh but we do have some
tweets coming in and uh Miami's secret
weapon in the second oh you saw Caitlyn
Clark from Iowa we need her right now
she she would probably keep falling oh
my gosh I mean that's that's
generational Talent right there I can't
even I can't even express watching her
games
there's times I'll be in the bus
screaming they're like what's up I'm
like man she is going berserk all right
so your history you had a lot of success
here at Miami how is it watching this
laronega surge these last few years
making these runs what is it like being
a fan
man it's it's the one of the greatest
streets I can honestly get you know
because between him and Mrs L which is
his wife
um they're they have genuine love and I
think that is one of the best things as
as far as his coaching is that he gives
you genuine love he makes you feel
comfortable and ready to play in that
trust so to watch him do what he's doing
now I mean I'm not surprised man he's
one of the greatest coaches there's a
reason why I went to um you know and
um this isn't the first time he's here I
could tell you legitimately love that
man absolutely like he's a really good
dude oh he's like I mean why not and the
Dancing Yeah when I first got there
actually when I got injured my first
practice and
um the first two people I seen was him
and Mrs L and every other day I call her
mama L yeah
um she was bringing me cookies and all
this extra stuff and missed and Coach
out you know he's calling and making
sure I'm good and whatnot and
um you know it really just shows the
type of person he is yeah why did his
offenses play so free you know it hasn't
been a great offensive performance
tonight but you watch Miami over the
course of the whole season and it's
Jordan Miller it's Isaiah Wong it's
Nigel I mean all these guys they it's
almost like they take turns but they
have great feel for when somebody gets
hot they feed that guy why does he
curate such a healthy place to play I
would say from what what I know
personally
um you know
it's everything's not given you have to
earn that you know when I first got
there he's like oh you're not starting
right now you have to earn that respect
you have to show me what you're capable
of doing and I think over time these
players have consistently showed what
they're capable of doing he just oh you
got that trust you you you're allowed to
do that a little bit more often and I
think just the type of coach that he is
especially with that you know that
genuine love that I consistently have
said
um it gives those players the utmost
confidence to play the best of the that
they can
what was it like playing at Miami you
know you think about the weather the
city The Nightlife I mean as a you know
going there in college I mean was it
everything I mean because it sounds
awesome I mean it sounds amazing it
sounds amazing I would say it is amazing
I mean we have the best weather
consistently I mean winter time I'm from
Pennsylvania where in Pennsylvania right
in Pennsylvania
my brother went to Albright no kidding
so Redding you want to talk about
middle of nowhere so you went from there
to Miami yes I may wow shout out to the
coach L man shout out to coach l so
you're walking like yeah what is it like
as a college kid in Miami I mean it's
amazing you know it's a completely
different world as far as you know the
weather is beautiful
um it's a private school so you have
one of the highest academics you know
you know I want to go for pre-med I
didn't get to officially do pre-med but
um as far as academics and planning the
ACC and then living in Miami I mean you
have the best of all worlds you know and
um the food is amazing you know
we have off there you can mess around
and go to the beach and just unplug and
relax so the ability to do a lot of
other things
um is it's one of the best blessings you
can get you know I enjoy going to Miami
if I had the opportunity to pick us
another school it would be um again
how often do you get to watch your Miami
highlights
when people send me them here and there
you know I I sure love to dwell on the
past when I have time and whatnot but uh
usually it's my father sending me stuff
or my mother my grandma I'm like oh
remember you did this and you did that
um but I try to stay current and be
present with the team and seeing how
coachella's coaching and things and
whatnot oh sorry no please what are your
thoughts on the dunk contest and are you
in um committed to do this man I I was
considering this year wow um but I'm
highly considering next year to join the
doctor I mean if you have a nickname
like Skywalker I have no choice you have
to do it wow I would love to though I
would say this year was a little bit
better than last year yep you know it's
hard Mac McClung yes yeah
weird though that he wasn't in the I
know he's been up and down and he's been
in the NBA but
does it why why is it not the same as
before where it was such a marquee event
how do we get it back to that I would
say it's it's hard because every other
year we're trying to change another way
of you know whether it's like two on two
or you got to do this you got to do that
the rules consistently change a lot I
think we just gotta what makes it hard
is I mean if we're being honest Zach
Levine and Aaron Gordon kind of ruined
the dunk contest
nobody's going to be able to replicate
uh jumping from the free throw line
between the legs but we're going lifting
your body like this on the mascot or
like Zach Levine doing a 360 from the
free throw
so I would say uh it takes time I think
it's gonna come back you know we have a
lot of high flowers you got players like
Shaden sharp who just entered the league
and um who are you know very exciting
players so
um I'm very optimistic on the dunk
contest
I feel like you're a little bit excited
Matt I feel like the inspiration that's
my voice that's my boy man that was fun
to watch yeah he gave me he gave me some
inspiration for sure oh man all right
second half is getting going the
13-point lead is 15. Poplar they're
showing right now hasn't made a shot
just as of yet
but Miami trying to claw back into this
one
[Applause]
what would you be saying to these guys
right now my goodness zero zero it's the
first half it's second half you know
don't overthink the gameplay
how you supposed to play I mean you made
it to the final four for a reason yeah
trusting the system trusting each other
and have fun man
this is an experience of a lifetime so
regardless of the outcome
we were just lock in man locked in Miami
able to get a basket there but also
sunogo got his 17th point which means
that I believe Robbie hit his I need one
more 17 and a half I know you had 17
plus so you're good I'm good all right
Lonnie how many people hit you guys up
now and yell at you for ruining their
parlay
that's the new NBA thing isn't it oh yes
that's I mean honestly that's been
around for a little while I would say as
of this year it probably has gotten out
a little
I'm sorry Lonnie
I'm sorry this is this is Seth was that
that was was that a center sorry no that
was Caravan okay
um
I mean it's been an amazing year
[Applause]
over yeah
we're locked in right now look look man
oh
good board and other shots that Poplar
was drilling against Texas he was
awesome against those guys all right
game's all about runs baby
game is all about runs all we need is
that one run catch a rhythm within the
team the flow to energy the chemistry
it's all going to connect like a
Bluetooth we good yeah they're gonna
need a run right here uh I mean I think
Wong's got to get going you gotta get
something easy buckets and maybe make
that run yeah once you get that
confidence up and also stopping sunogo
oh dude he's been free I feel like with
you need to kind of get a little
comfortable
see we're getting loose with the ball
yeah
there we go see this is going on oh wow
I'm shocked oh man wow I do not think
that's a foul he's going vertical I
thought it was straight up
so you start off in San Antonio right
when you start off your MBA career and
you're going there
mindset wise how do you think that's
different than other players mindsets
and their experience going to San
Antonio yeah
you went from Miami to San Antonio you
know
um as far as like
the transition or the coaching culture
the coaching and all that stuff um I
would say the greatest thing was
knowing that I'm about to be under one
of the greatest coaches of all time no
doubt you know when you're young an
internal League there's so much stuff
that you have to learn yeah and there's
so much that you have to adjust to yeah
and I would say being around coach pop
I mean he's really made it easier making
being decisive understanding the game
more watching film you know
um he used to say things you know you
owe it to your teammates you know to be
your best self so
um I think being there was as a rookie
is one of the greatest blessings you can
get gives you that Foundation gives you
that Foundation under understanding how
to be a professional even when things
aren't going your way right
um you know you know to go from Lara
to Popovich is pretty awesome yes
and it's a it's a complete 180 switch
that's coachella's a very loving dude
and then Coach pop is like a all right I
think I'm gonna say some things yeah I'm
gonna tell you the truth but tell you
the truth you know it ain't gonna be
sweet all the time is there any any
place where he's maybe misunderstood or
something that people don't know about
Greg Popovich than when you go and play
for him you think man I never thought
that it's all what it is yeah what you
see is what you get you know coach pop
is very direct he's very decisive and
understanding you know and it's not I
would say the difference is you can
you can't receive what he's saying as
him yelling and being mad at you you
have to understand what he's saying
because he wants the best out of you I
would they they would say if he's not
screaming at you then you should be
worried you know so um most of most of
him is just it's out of love he knows
what what you can do and he wants you to
be your best
all right Miami down 18. this is sort of
the pace they would want
all right match up on the wing this
mismatch I gotta take advantage of this
yeah they have to look everybody's
clearing oh are they gonna let them
switch
huh
[Applause]
oh they got him good time sir good
offense okay okay okay
Lonnie's making me feel like a Miami fan
now I switched halfway through the last
game to San Diego State and it worked
out yeah
you guys come back from this
this is all time yes this is all time
yes that's the positive
the negative
I don't think there's necessarily no
negative I mean I'm a very positive
person and to to get to where they have
gotten this year is impeccable
especially because of last year
and not only did you do history was last
year you got even better the year after
yes and hey man nobody expected us to
make it to this final four and they lost
three starters I mean you lose Charlie
Moore and you lose uh big fella
wardenberg and you lose Kim Augustine I
mean and here you are at the final four
it's an incredible season for them you
got a connection with any of these guys
um I know Isaiah wall I'm pretty cool
with him um Anthony Walker we're not
related but uh we're pretty cool so I
know a couple of the players
um but Isaiah Wong I've known him since
dang their high school did anyone any
alums have a chance in in your year
there to pour into you at all while you
were there say that again when you were
at Miami did any alums have a chance to
talk to you or did you kind of feel like
you were setting your own pace
um not necessarily I would say
um being around like players like Bruce
Brown yeah
um and DeJuan Bruce was really one of
the main go-to players when I was there
you know he was one of the reasons why I
really wanted to go to um just seeing
him play and how free he was able to
play so
um I would say my teammates just made it
amazing you know and then having coach
oh
um he knows so many people what's it
like being on the other side where you
have these young guys that are super
excited to hear from you and you get to
pour into them what's that like it's
it's insane man because I mean I've been
in a league for five years I'm 24 years
old and to say that I'm actually growing
older I've never kind of seen this
aspect of the aspect of life but um it's
it's rewarding you know it understand I
understand where they're coming from and
to be able to help out as much as I can
you know that's that's what five years
in the league and he's 24. it's crazy
that's crazy what's it like seeing
LeBron James do what he does every day
it explains to me why he made it to the
final so many years consistently you
know rather win or loss you know he
he's just all in man you know like he
knows what he wants to do
he's very consistent you know I'm a very
observant player you know I watch what
people people do and I tend to try and
see what I can add on to my game with
that
um for him to be in year 20 and always
be in the in the gym first working out
already got a sweat watching the film
talking telling us certain little things
to do it's ridiculous you know there's
times where a possession might happen
and we'll run that possession back he's
like I need you to do this now you'll
just walk to a bucket just because he
knows the game so well he knows how
teams he says next time do that and then
you just do it just do it oh it's gonna
come right to you like this dude is a a
living robot man he knows the game
inside and out he knows every other
team's plays you know he knows just how
they're going to play A.D what we might
need to do so he's a very uh he's a
leader you know he's he's a vocalized
leader and he leads by actions as well
man
y'all are dangerous yes they do not need
you in the playing it's a scary
situation
I mean what is Adia back to back 38
point games
it's a unicorn he's looking healthy he's
a living unicorn I was I was telling
coaches the other day I was like
he can stop playing basketball for three
years and just come on the court
unconditioned and probably give you 25
points off of 10 shots he's just he's
the natural one of the rarest players
I've ever watched play the game
meanwhile Miami is now down just 60.
don't go in unbelievable mic goodness
it's a nasty shot
I mean that was good defense it was
it's probably a bad shot honestly
but none of it goes in it's definitely a
bad shot the only reason it's a good
shot because it went in yeah but
get in there we go let's go all right
right back
we're not letting loose we good man
Lonnie do you think Miami with nil and
laronega can become one of the you know
more popular places in college
basketball
[Music]
yes yes sir
I like your question though nil plus
laronega plus Miami equals New Era I
mean who wouldn't want to go play it I
get it I would say it you have the best
of everything you know the ACC is one of
the best
conferences in the league consistently
you know you're playing against Duke
North Carolina NC State so not only do
you have great competition on the court
but all good pass
I'm out
12. yes sir that's all we need a little
run we know about 12 look getting
getting the Jitters out feeling good we
sawing fast breaks threes good defense
that was a man's rebound absolutely who
wouldn't want to play in Miami so you
have anything that you could possibly
imagine
academics
[Applause]
great coach beautiful weather I mean
winter time you don't got word you don't
got worried about it being 20 degrees
it's 75 and beautiful yeah what do you
guys think when you go to like Boston
College and you're like these four guys
you know what's funny it's funny because
after I remember we had a game in Boston
College when we came home it was
freezing in Boston we get home and like
we have like sweat jackets on as soon as
we go off the plane we're like man we
gotta take this off it's hot you know
and you know you might have a bad game
if
to come back to Miami after having a not
so good game and just feeling that
weather it makes you just unplug a
little bit you know and get ready for
that next one I wanna I want the
audience right now to give Lonnie some
confidence can Miami make a comeback we
are going to do this in the chat in the
chat you write yes or no and it's gonna
automatically add it up remember Lonnie
is here the deficit now is only 12. it
was just 20. can Miami make a comeback
type in yes or no in the chat and we
want to see it populate all right for
sure
I love the love man that's that's what
yes I love the optimism I love the
positivity
out there yes do you have you taken a
peek from this angle go look go look at
your student section compared to UConn
so you can stand up and go over there if
you want I should take a picture of this
you can if you want
that is a surprise I didn't think Miami
but look at your student section
compared to UConn student section
because we go hard it's already winning
and look at how y'all are partying the
game isn't over yet look at these guys
they they just oh we good man the energy
is about to transfer over the Vibes is
transferring over I'm not gonna lie
though the Yukon student section is
pretty disappointing student session
this is pretty weak right here but week
showing by the Huskies see that's what
I'm saying you want to go to a Yukon
when it's cold section or you want to go
to um where it's beautiful and we got a
beautiful student station that's
cheering us oh the vote is now 50 50.
which is good it's not bad 50 of people
thinking y'all are gonna come back from
this is big 50 from three is great yes
it is that's how I'm Gonna Take It
man
Miami
that sounds like an amazing college
experience yes a different one than
99.9 of oh man college student athletes
have
yeah like our Miami athletes how did
they get treated in the city of Miami
you're not the Dolphins you're not the
Heat I would say the hardest thing is
when people think of University of Miami
they think we're in South Beach Coral
Gables is yes Coral Gables is about 30
45 minutes from like south from like
Miami where people think it's like you
know everything else
so I would say we have Coral Gables on
lock you know the fans in Coral Gable
are extremely loving I mean the fans in
Miami period are extreme 11 when they
see with that orange orange and uh green
I like this they're going press right
now so 7-0 run in the last 50 seconds
Miami pressure in the ball this is what
you want to do against UConn right with
their guard play especially if Hawkins
is sick beat him up you got to mix it up
somehow maybe speed it up maybe add some
traps or whatever mix up the defense
just to kind of disrupt their Rhythm man
I like the Press too to just take some
time off the clock
baby get some Stills plus it's gonna be
a tough shot no matter what it is it is
oh wow didn't foul go any other way
that's a foul that's a foul that was a
foul that was bad if that turns into a
bucket that was blatant not a lot of
fouls called in this game so far
I wish a whistle fest last one we're
giving teas over like breathing on it oh
my goodness I think he said that the
other way yeah all right
second
yeah think about it we're seven minutes
into the second half and there's been
two fouls called that's crazy this game
is flowing by
just letting them play
[Applause]
I like Isaiah Wong huh I'm so Saucy
about him man I love a zero fear pure
score
and he's only gotten better about a year
and that's the best thing is you love to
see an improvement consistently
all right Yukon try oh good pressure
again dangerous situation locked in now
oh they're not guarding jacks on the
perimeter good D there wow oh they got
to come away with it
oh it up just can't let him score
geez he's the only one when he touches
it that I'm nervous everyone else I'm
like you could shoot he can jump huh
who's that Sunoco wow hey boy number 44.
00 yeah he's got oh yeah
hit that
big shot come on turn me up come on now
this is getting nasty oh the positive
power of Lonnie Walker the fourth is
invaded the stadium here at NRG all good
frequencies I'm giving out all good
reasons it's when you stood up
UConn looking for a shot and they caught
that's a two though that's got to be a
two
was that Hawkins yeah it's Hawkins
I don't like that look I think you got
to go back to Sunoco right there I right
after the last one I mean they can't
stop no mayor doesn't want to foul
oh we got a shoe malfunction on the
Hurricanes bench Jeremy is getting
screen time does he really run like that
I need some real hustle oh remember we
had a lot of bets on sunogo stats and he
oh he made it uh so your bet was 17 he's
got 19 and seven one more rebound than
Hans Bros feeling good and oh just a
casual 89 from the floor omer's got four
boards too so wow I need two boards from
uh snow going I need a mirror not to get
any gotcha it's gonna stay low-key on
the rebounds
he was sick yesterday he didn't practice
yesterday look at his face right now
he's tired see look that's what I like
to see I'm sorry
yeah we hope he's okay but at the same
time that's what we like to see we gotta
we gotta attack that and he missed the
second one okay we gotta attack him put
him in all the defensive schemes man
absolutely right I think one of my bets
for tomorrow is how many times will Left
Coast switch sides how many flip-flops
will we get
I do like the strategy of like why are
we not attacking Hawkins yes sir oh
goodbye yes sir get in yes sir
I'm on now
come on now this is great this is the
kind of game we want to see
sunogo's not even on the court now
I kind of want to watch this game
you can go up there and watch I'll watch
it with you come on oh boy he wanted to
stop there
there we go
oh it's going up
yes sir
here we go
oh the Lottie Walker positive energy
it's an eight-point game it's an
eight-point game
can you correspond sunogo on the bench
oh trouble uh-huh
shot
no no good oh what a board what a board
that was big that was big is a good
player man he's he's gonna be a problem
trash compactor bro
what a run here
long with 12 points Miller with nine
points Juan kind of did this in the
Texas game too though steps into it that
looked like a half second late that shot
all right let's go
[Applause]
see we we we we don't woke up now
uh-huh
you don't want to shoot oh Hawkins oh
man
he won't shoot
all right
now he's had a good game
I'm messing up I don't know how to act
I'm sorry no he's explosive he really is
yeah wow
some people can handle playing sick
Tyler he's that guy gets your mind off
the game
you don't have to think oh those were
some big answers right there by UConn
I go back to Hawkins I I do I think he's
an explosive score maybe he's got his
confidence going I'd get him another
shot wait look at him hunched over wow
that's bad what are we doing
all right we see what time we see what
type time they are we good walk it off
oh
[Applause]
man that would have been a big stealing
finish
oh sorry I really won't watch this game
no I get it you know what Lonnie it's
been a pleasure get down there and go
watch the game okay and who's my voice
yes we will see you good luck
thank you good luck with everything
brother yes sir
yes I get it he gave us enough of the
vibes
he did
[Music]
man 20 24 years old
it's crazy when when guys go in the
league after their freshman year and
you're looking at in their five years
pro and they're like they're 24. and
they're like it's crazy that people
think I'm older I know it's like yeah
you're 24.
it goes by fast too though yeah
well because you guys don't stop
it's all year round oh yeah everything
and so there's you don't really have a
lot of moments to sit back and go can
you believe I'm in the NBA so when
you're not one of the Superstar players
you are just trying to survive you are
literally just trying
you're year to year it is such a
stressful place to be I don't think
people understand that from uh and once
you get a long-term contract it's a
different deal but when you're just
trying to make your mark in the NBA more
so it's like a second round pick or
somebody that that is trying to play
their way into the free agent if every
game feels so important every practice
feels so important it's just it's a very
uncomfortable place to be sure even
though you're making a lot of money and
you're playing in the greatest
basketball league in the world it's a
really
weird feeling it really is every
possession yeah I mean you turn it over
in practice so you miss a couple of
shots you're like the sky is falling
yeah like how could I do this it's tough
that's a great Point Robbie talks about
because sometimes as a bench player in
the NBA especially you get in three
minutes into the game and you look at a
lot of the analytics they go by the per
32 or whatever minute
you want to do work in that time you
don't care when you get your your
minutes because you're just trying to
survive into the next year and try to do
something positive even if it's a
blowout and a lot of people don't
understand that hey it's a blowout why
are you playing so hard well I'm trying
to make the most of my minutes when I
get because everybody's watching this
tape yes and they're going to say well
Tyler Hansbrough competes his ass off
yeah every time he's on the court yeah
and and that that is why that is that's
a great Point let's take a look at a
possible MVP for Miami if they're able
to make this comeback it is another
trainer running out with sneakers and
Nigel Pack's been out out of this game
because of this for a while you know if
if I'm a coach of the next uh the teams
that make the final I'm having my
trainers running Sprints up and back
from the locker room get used to the
Past you gotta be ready you never know
I also want to know what happened with
the sneaker why did the place we must
have blown out I would think all that
nil money at Miami and pack doesn't have
backup sneakers not Jordan Brandon North
Carolina Adidas yeah they'd have them
yeah
yeah if Wendy's was in charge of
sneakers he would have had them Wendy's
are Burgers a square so you don't have
to be
uh UConn up 13 now 9 35 left
Yukon seizing Back Control Miami had
gotten the deficit to just eight
few big threes
and then Hawkins really stepped up big
thus far in the last two possessions
they're doing all this with Sunoco on
the bench big steal looks like Hawkins
is out too so they're gonna have to rely
on somebody this is the time yeah who
scores for UConn right now
how is this Yukon unit defensively
I think solid I mean calcaterra is not
going to be good
oh there you go clinging with his size
the effect just intimidated long with
that shot so that's uh you know I
thought he was going to go up with that
yeah like normally he would yeah like
Robin said he's coming to pack it he
just cleans everything up so you can
really pressure the guards I wish there
was a way that that could be tracked
statistically like shots affected or or
like
player closest to the ball when turnover
occurs or something because like that
was all clinging yep oh yeah that ball
should have gone up but fear caused that
to not go up and Robbie knows this like
Zach Edie from Purdue he didn't have a
lot of block shots but he changed a lot
of shots because of his size
I mean this is your backup center like
he's not your normal backup no your
starting center has been hooping too but
what's his story who's that he's from
Bristol Connecticut where ESPN is I I
don't think that Connecticut is
necessarily known for their hotbed of
high school basketball talent but he was
a top 40 kid highly recruited and he
looks like it man when they grow up
right near campus that's pretty sweet
yeah no doubt
yeah that's a heck of a heck of a tool
to have in your as your backup
and what year is he he's a freshman yeah
stop he'll play it he'll be in he'll be
an NBA big he runs the floor you think
he'll come out this year I don't know
about this year but I I think he will
play I'm just thinking long-term UConn
you got him after sunogo that's pretty
unbelievable
oh here they go
I feel for Lonnie having to be on camera
to watch at least they came back a
little bit but when I tell you that we
did this in Wes Welker he could not
handle it with Texas Tech
have stuff
man
that was like a blue blood type of cheer
right there too
yeah
that was that was impressive well their
student section's not blue blood that's
for sure that's a fact I can't believe
it also that is a that is a blue blood
thing to be upset at your student
section Alabama football upset of their
student section that's true because the
students are the ones that always take
it for granted but a true blue blood
program it's the alums and it's the
locals that are like I'm here every day
champ they've got to be on spring break
or something that's the worst I've ever
seen at a final four it's a far trip I
think I don't know I mean I know they go
how many kids go to UConn that's really
poor
I want to see I'd be surprised if
they're trying to stay back in UConn
yeah in Connecticut over Houston I
agreed so UConn has a total
undergraduate enrollment of just under
000.
how does that compare to Purdue and
North Carolina Purdue's like 45 or 40
000. Purdue is 37 000.
and North Carolina is 20 000. North
Carolina would have that thing Juiced
North Carolina be packed Syracuse is 12
000. and that thing would be jam-packed
is that Calhoun they're showing walking
up I didn't see his face oh no I don't I
don't think it is
[Applause]
I don't know but
dapping up everybody
oh that's Colangelo oh Jerry Jerry
Colangelo
he probably called you a few times over
the years
now he stays into more of the 515. he
doesn't deal with the three on three uh
no that's not that's not so much his his
setting man
all right
I don't think they're coming back yeah
[Applause]
eight to play I think that's that's
that's a fair assumption damn
I'm glad Lonnie gave us some hope though
he's a very positive guy very positive
very positive
is that uh rare for an NBA player no but
I I think that
some guys
it just it varies I don't think it's
it's a it's not a one way or the other I
mean fear can motivate people too just
because you're not all positive all the
time doesn't mean it's a bad thing I
think a lot of people come in here and
think oh you got to be positive about
everything well fear motivates people
fear makes people work too so let's not
knock having somebody you know I don't
want to have a negative uh you know
outcome so I'm gonna work a little bit
harder no doubt yeah all right so if
it's Yukon San Diego State if it's Miami
San Diego State uh how do we feel about
Monday's game Robbie
I think UConn's putting on a show and I
mean San Diego State terrific win
unbelievable game but these guys are my
favorite con size I mean they do they do
have the the the bodies and the people
to throw with the depth and some size
but UConn's the best team left and the
best team period and they're looking
like that right now because I saw Miami
last weekend in person I was
so impressed with the way they beat
Texas right
what do you think Ty
well I think UConn's going to win this
one and I don't need him getting
rebounds but oh no what is that that
might be six that's that's his sixth
rebound oh boy oh
um no but I will say UConn's done a
great job and they've done you know a
very good job in this tournament but San
Diego State they are deep and they also
play defensive can make it an ugly rough
game which UConn runs sophisticated sets
and they get a lot of movement but maybe
that physicality and that depth can can
bother UConn I wouldn't say that it's
going to be a cupcake or just an easy
game for UConn I could see San Diego
State coming out and give them a run
think about like Hawkins flying off
those pin Downs when you got somebody
just biting you off of your screen like
that that's not fun to play against
especially in the second half you're a
little fatigued you're coming off I'm
thinking though about
I was cursed the dribble handoffs from
San Diego State and like you think
that's going to work against Uconn and
then you do like I'm just thinking about
Bradley trying to go in the lane against
these bigs of Uconn and like having
success Bradley made a ton of contested
Shots tonight he made a ton of threes
wow that's a rebound
I think the Hurley thing has been really
surprising yes
[Applause]
Tracy to talk about
Danny Hurley was born 48 years ago
yes oh here we go highlight bye
he's a big time athlete and that in the
business we call an exclamation point
fast break
he's a potential second rounder if he
improves his jump shot he could shoot
yeah I think he's definitely an NBA
player he's averaging I think seven
seven and seven in the tournament yes he
was
I just saw a stat Miami's missed 12
layups tonight wow what else they are
Kemba Walker Ray Allen a Mecca Okafor
and Rip Hamilton are among the Yukon
greats here who have also have Bob
Hurley senior Bobby Hurley and Bill
Murray in their Corner in Miami's eight
of 20 from layups wow it's terrible
and a lot of that goes to the Biggs of
Uconn so it's like what Tyler was saying
they're they're just cleaning it up you
drive it in there you're trying to
challenge him and you got two seven
Footers that are going vertical and
challenging every layup hey now this
game's not over they said we heard you
left Co they did we heard you I was
motivating them
[Applause]
big three in the corner four for three
Miami four of seven in the three from
three this half
can they get some stops looking down low
to the big man
partying them up right hand hook oh good
good hands by long
going the long way oh no oh touch that
why did he touch that wow for their ball
it was right that was going up Yukon so
this just happened long fast break going
out of bounds knocked down
yeah I think that was going out he was
he was trying to bat it uh
I think Wong or or maybe even hit the
out of bounds off of the Yukon guy
right ah they zoomed up no I think that
was in
calcaterra I love that name
man that stinks
uh
we got a cut
Isaiah Wong
such an interesting player Wong I
haven't really seen anyone who's like
body oh so is out right there whose body
movements are like that
you talk about Wong or who it's very
it's just very
um
it just doesn't seem normal
things are just all over the place yeah
he's kind of loose with it like that
he's hit a monster empty tournament
though outside of the Drake game
he's bald
that's funny I think I picked Drake and
Iona
and like the two other teams are here at
the Final Four
[Applause]
a lot of screens oh my goodness they
call it a block the only thing you could
say is he maybe didn't give him room to
land Maybe
if anything that just feels like
incidental Roger is a pretty good ref
too yeah
I think that's what they're gonna say is
he's coming into that jump when does he
catch it
well
just depends on how you interpret the
rule
but he is there
oh
easy
put in there for Benson
come on Isaiah
do something crazy
five minutes now five minutes and
Counting
Miami's gonna look back at that first
half and kick themselves
because they've been playing well in the
second half
they got him there for the foul
I'm gonna use a line from Tyler the
fouls right now six for Miami that was
just the second foul for UConn you're
saying we got some evening I could be
maybe some Ticky tacks
going the other way like we did in game
one I could see that being called you
know college that I keep it close in the
fouls uh yeah because at the end of the
game that nobody asks about it it's
amazing how that happens you know you
think that every game is is close in the
fouls it's it's so crazy to think that
hey one team's not defensively as
disciplined as another and they don't
foul more that that can happen as well I
never really like trying to keep the
fouls close but I understand the theory
but it's because the media has small
brains and at the end we go oh I got a
sheet and it says that there's this many
thousand that many fouls and that
number's wrong but they don't not a lot
of media watches the game and they don't
realize hey if we took away this
two-minute stretch where you called a
lot it was completely incorrect for the
it's and I'm media so I'll say it let's
take a look at our picks and how they're
doing and see if these guys on the Big
Red Couch are doing well we have green X
for the ones that have already hit and
if you bet on positive sunogo you were
great omir what's that rebounds Robbie
omir is looking at six right now six
okay so that's sitting okay I don't
wanna I don't want to just go too
positive not comfortable uh and you
count by seven Yukon by five
we're on the right side currently
Hawkins has the neon green light this
dude is oh wow
and was that the same guy that hit the
three at the end of the first half man
take a look at this one pump fake Drive
gets it and one
huge three-point play in the first half
huge three-point play in the second half
he's had a good freshman year he's part
of the all freshman team in the Big East
and he's skilled he can shoot he's got
good size the fact that every time a guy
hits a shot you guys tell me he's a
freshman for UConn as well that's crazy
and they're rosters crazy talented
technically now the NBA draft changes
things yes
I think everyone could come back
besides Tristan noon but Newton might
have a code year Hawkins is a sophomore
Jackson's a junior caravan's a redshirt
freshman sonogo's a junior
what do you think about this tweet when
I watch this Yukon team I see 06 Florida
to
talk to it Tyler don't hold back you
talking about what Joe Kim knows they're
the pros that Florida did tell the truth
maybe I mean no they're not as good as
Florida the Florida team had no beasts
no Joe Kim knows much more athletic than
any of these bigs that they have Al
Horford could stretch the floor he was I
mean Corey Brewer's a lottery pick yeah
like yeah we didn't talk about Corey
Brewer can lock down
Lockdown Defender on the perimeter yeah
this is not uh that was what we like to
call a hot take or somebody's just
trying to say something Florida went
back to back too yeah take that away
maybe if he meant that hey this team
could all come back next year all right
I could see that but here's Florida had
top end NBA Talent UConn rolled away
it's funny because I was when y'all you
both came in at different times today in
the hotel lobby and I was sitting there
and I'm watching all the pregame and I
go this is something we do in college
sports where in a lot of sports when a
team wins we get very hyperbolic and we
go where do they rank all the time even
if it's just a normal team in a in a
certain year and I went
four seat five seat five seat nine seed
I go are people really gonna do it this
year like last year or here we are or
you know two thousand I think what was
it when it was all number ones was that
09 or was that 2011. I think it was 0-9
where it was UCLA was a year North
Carolina Michigan State wasn't no it was
the year that you lost right yeah it was
Kansas North Carolina
yeah that's one of those years where you
go I need historical context yeah
I don't think any of these are up for
like that Florida team that's up for
like their best college basketball team
yes yes yes and this is great yeah this
is a good but we're not I don't know I
agree so no going up matching up with
Joe Kim Noah like what are we doing no
Joe Kim's much
Joakim knows has
better length than I think they had
seven Pros on their team
yeah list them off all right let me let
me confirm that but I'm joking Noah's up
there with your kind of intensity too I
like Noah I
faced his uh Lawrenceville Prep High
School team
and I had never seen a high school kid
yelling at referees like that before it
was incredible are you talking noise to
them no I was not I was sitting there
being like I'm gonna keep this program
because my name's in it with Joe Kim
Noah all right let me read these off
yeah Taurean green wore the socks bro Al
Horford Pro still playing Corey Brewer
really good NBA player Noah stud NBA yes
Lee Humphrey great college player didn't
play in the NBA yeah Chris Richard NBA
player Walter Hodge great overseas Pro
most baits freshman most Spates yeah
they had one won a championship NBA
players he was the first round pick by
the Sixers yep
yep they were loaded hell yeah wow they
were loaded
no and this team is deep and they're
very low but there's also you know it's
a Yukon fan getting really excited yeah
no I actually know who that was that was
a radio guy in Tennessee and that's why
I think it was a hot take ah okay
they are all friend they are all threats
UConn basketball
[Applause]
man
yeah we'll see if San Diego State can
mush it up
we also got to see who comes back for
UConn I don't think Hawkins is coming
back I think he's he's a top pick snow
go I don't know if they win it would he
want to come back right not test and
then Andre Jackson also could leave
early to the defense by some over there
ah
I did like though that 06 Florida team
young Billy Donovan you know Protege of
Rick Pitino like the young dude that
played Hurley I you know that maybe but
[Applause]
oh good cut
wow back to back good cuts and then he's
hanging on rims I think it's night night
yep yeah that was that right there was
the
cut to the cut and let's cut it out it's
a great play really nice
really really
I mean Miami really threw two Haymakers
late and UConn took them both on the
chin and then delivered themselves and
every time it was a different player
yeah I think Miami tried to switch it up
a little bit when they went to full
court pressure to mix everything try to
get a little an easy turnover for a
bucket but they couldn't sustain that
Hawkins came in hit some big shots snow
go had a heck of a game now you're
seeing Andre Jackson make Cuts uh yeah
they just don't have the power that
UConn does and Miami had some I don't
want to say desperation because you're
trying whatever you can to win the game
but within the press and they were even
just randomly trapping in the half glass
they were yeah just to try to force
turnovers and honestly their best
offense tonight has been getting on
transitional turnovers and then the
offensive glass in the first half and
then some Isaiah Wong but I think Poplar
as Poplar made a shot
welcome Poplar is 0.0 for seven wow
Nigel packs three for nine Long's been
good but he's four of ten I mean they
needed this game they needed to be in
the in the mid to high 70s for them to
win because they were gonna have to get
to track me
I think what's incredible too UConn's
won every game by 15 or more and they're
on track to do it again that will be a
heck of a thing if they're able to now
if they do have a San Diego State
I mean the fact that they've done that
against Iona St Mary's Arkansas Gonzaga
is pretty amazing jeez
as long as omir doesn't get rebounds
we're good have you got any more
he's at seven oh wow okay but I didn't
the number's 10 so I feel good about
that
I will say Miami's gonna be shooting a
lot of Threes though so he's gonna have
chance for rebounds
[Applause]
do it so no go
oh all right
those defensive rebounds are where omir
can definitely get him too oh
wow wow that no goaltending
that was kind of European almost knocked
that thing knocking it off the rim
all right back to the Blue Bloods
discussion
there's also something about these Yukon
jerseys with the big dog head and like
the red trim I like the the lettering
too yeah old school lettering it brings
me back to like Khalid El Amin yeah yeah
oh they've had some beef oh Sunoco think
about the element team
or then you go on to the rooms Van
Gordon which one is
he was in that mix Rip Hamilton Jake
foskel talk about like they've had so
many Rebecca Okafor like serious Pros
yeah Rudy Gay came from fruity gay is
awesome he lost to George Mason uh with
larenegger right yep in the tournament
they had a loaded team too like gay is
one of those guys that
remember how like it was always like
who's the next Jordan in the 90s pretty
gay was like who's the next of that like
Kobe type and he fit that profile man
like I mean he was six eight oh he had
everything athlete Rudy Gay was awesome
but they also the size they had Hilton
Armstrong Josh Boone wow I forgot
there's so many more guys they could
just throw out at you Charlie Villanueva
yeah like cheese
I love tasheem sabit in college too he
was so good oh man
he was so good
we played him in the tournament and you
would just get to the room be like lay
up and he's just coming over and he's
sending that thing into the stands
I don't know why when I think if she's
the beat I think of Adam Morrison
okay well
the only thing in doubt is the omir
rebounds here all right so because it's
looking like Uconn and San Diego State
we are going to start the poll now who
do you have winning the title UConn or
San Diego State comment Yukon or comment
SDSU we'll get that going in this last
minute and 18 seconds as UConn goes on
they are currently up 15. so the average
will remain true if they hold on to this
15-point lead
oh
wow don't get hurt now
and he's made some threes and drove the
ball a couple times so let's say you
guys are Yukon and you're up and you
know everyone's like oh win with Grace
yeah but you also like the shot clock's
going down is there a correct way to do
this no you there's there's no harm in
shooting at the end of the clock
I think yeah what are you supposed to do
just give the ball the ref yeah I mean
you could take a shot clock violation
but I
I don't see any problems it's a turnover
on the stat sheet yeah I understand why
the shot attempt goes up I have no
problem with it uh
I don't know I'm always feels I always
feel bad for the the player that has to
you know sit there and hold the ball and
let the shot clock or take time expire
and just take the turnover are you
seeing the NBA where guys will pass
somebody else yeah because that's the
same thing what I'm saying about fouls
on the stat sheet at the end and and
what you were saying is why don't they
understand context
after the season when we're all looking
at the stats and your assistant turnover
ratio is messed up no one's gonna be
like oh well he had it at the end of the
show like that's all I forgot it's like
the half court shots too I remember
three quarter courtship I remember when
I was doing the NFL a lot there was one
year where ocum in Europe had six sacks
in one game against the Eagles
and at the end of the year he finished
with 10 sacks and the whole offseason
was double digit sack man I go he had
four sacks in 16 other games but the
numbers can lie like they're three-point
Shooters who will never in the NBA shoot
a three-quarter court shot oh yeah
because your percentage is so important
what's going on uh current poll
standings UConn getting 73 percent to
San Diego State I would say that feels
accurate I'm curious what the spread is
going to be for Monday night
I'm not curious what the spread is at
Wendy's burgers nuggets frosties Wendy's
eat it
I think San Diego State's a better
better team than Miami in my personal
opinion in a match-up from UConn Harley
shot oh that's two all right we may have
missed one too were they shots that we
saw or are they shots that happened
this should count is two shots
uh chat works of art Miami forgot how to
get rebounds this game is done real
sports fan Big L for Florida teams today
oh that's true very true there you go
that's a third shot of Hurley man can I
get two more I set the line at four and
a half
can we get another back to the game back
to Hurley my bet would be Tracy Wolfson
right now telling a story about Saint
Anthony's you're gonna get a hugging
shot I feel like I could get a hugging
shot at these no embrace
oh dimes Drew Timmy or Tyler hansborough
bigger college basketball legend I'm
going Hans Pearl he's got titles winning
matters
Timmy's a great player
like this kid's gonna have to dribble
Tyler had a mustache he'd get the same
amount of uh love I would shave you
would shave oh see that that stinks he
was trying to just run the clock out he
just got called for a five second count
oh that's funny
oh leads down to 13.
how many rebounds does omir have he's
out of the game okay I got my head on it
he's got seven
last game
and that ladies and gentlemen here on
the final four live presented by Wendy's
that is it UConn knocks off Miami
[Applause]
72-59 a 13-point win double digits
strong from the jump took punches for
Miami battled back and just handled it
the entire way and they are going to the
fifth National Championship in schools
history and all of it from the turn of
1999.
as impressive as you would have wanted
for a team that you picked in the very
beginning for your bracket they're
they're doing you proud Tyler
hansborough they're playing dominant but
say this isn't going to be easy on
Monday San Diego State's gonna give them
uh you know a different look than
they've seen all tournaments so I'm
looking forward to that game yeah what
are we thinking for Monday night well I
think the the big question will be does
Jordan Hawkins feel better and do you
want him to feel better with the way he
played tonight he was terrific again
he's explosive as Tyler talked about
UConn has
[Applause]
they've got everything that you want
they've got a dominant big they've got a
great backup big they can get out and
play fast they can play Slow certainly
the physicality and the defense of San
Diego State can they get into those
guards can they affect Andre Jackson
trying to run the show but there we saw
in that one tweet they have so many guys
that beat you now Caravan huge shot into
the half made some plays in the second
half I just I think that this UConn team
is is really really good all right so I
just want to go over our picks one more
time Tyler hansborough did you go two
for two in the Yukon game I think I did
he did Robbie Hummel did you go two for
two in the Yukon game I did
I am currently one for two but you have
time here Bobby Hurley's family is at
four they are interviewing him right now
Danny's got to make one copy about not
signing off until I get this final
Hurley shot his final four live
presented by Wendy's if they can show
Bobby Hurley one more time we go a
perfect six for six
the crew here looking at me going shut
up we want to go home we're done oh come
on that could have been Hurley wow very
oh is that our camera
remember showing Bobby Hurley does that
count does that count give me the green
check who do they just show on the CBS
broadcast just some random fans all
right you just got to make a comment
about how you know I'm something about
his dad or his brother come on Hurley uh
it has been an absolute honor doing this
with you guys tonight to Lonnie Walker
IV to Renee Montgomery to Kimball Walker
to Candace Parker did we have anybody
else join us I think that's where the
four it was an absolutely
let's go
six for six in the UConn game and we can
get out of here join us on Monday night
the crew is like oh of course Kansas
State yes Noelle joined us as well
absolute blast with you guys head to
Wendy's Candace Parker shocked a year's
supply of frosties we had a game winner
we had a team making their way to the
finals UConn San Diego State ready to go
Monday night hansborough will be there
Hama will be there will you be there
Renee Montgomery freestyling all that
and much more enjoy the rest of your
night y'all and enjoy the NCAA
Championship
foreign
[Music]
thank you